the variant of he who remains
the one he's been talking about the one
that he's so afraid of
is kang great bang is ben thomas
god oh they said the k word
iterations as he who remains says
reincarnation
baby hey reincarnation baby
incarnation baby how long will we get to
dance with this
devil in the details hopefully for the
next 20 years
i'm working for 20 years of majors
welcome back to new rock stars as we
move on from loki one of our guides
through the multiverse will be
kang but will this multiverse crisis be
resolved in the next few years in time
for a new big bad to arise
or are we now living permanently in a
marvel cinematic multiverse
how long is he who remains remaining
is he you know renting month to month or
is he executing squatters rights
this is the inside marvel our weekly
marvel discussion
we are currently in between loki and
marvel's what if but there's still so
much to talk about
i'm eric voss here with mt how you
feeling empty
i'm feeling good i like the rent
metaphor for uh kang i hope that uh
spider-man from the uh remy trilogy's
landlord is
the the landlord of the multiverse
because that'd be hilarious
so loki's now in the rear view mirror
but objects seem closer than they appear
of course including the question of how
permanent the chaos of the broken
timeline will be
in the mcu we are going to talk about
kang's future and who could be
behind the curtain that's behind him how
many layers of curtains are we dealing
with
plus other updates on spider-man no way
home black panther wakanda forever
ant-man the was quantum mania in moon
night but
first if you're still hoping to get the
latest obsession loki out of time shirt
for
loki this is your last call
last call but don't forget to also grab
our newest addition to the latest
obsession collection black widows the
red deep
both of these awesome shirts will soon
be locked away in the vault or possibly
pruned from the timeline forever
keep an eye out for our new releases
we're planning on launching
two brand new latest obsession shirts
for the next couple of weeks
one based on the disney plus series
marvel's what if and another that will
drop
as an exciting surprise so stay tuned
and check out all great merch options
here at newrockstarsmerch.com
but mt what's our big question this week
well our big question for today is
what is marvel's plan for kane is he the
new thanos or will he transition us to
another villain
who'll be the next then yeah so uh we've
been seeing some interesting quotes from
cast and crew in the days since the
finale
like the director kate herron said that
the casting of jonathan majors was the
decision that was made by
marvel studios quantum media director
peyton reed and herself
now she didn't mention any other
directors being part of that decision
interestingly not john watts or any of
the directors on any other disney plus
show
um but john watts is uh doing spider-man
no way home
and he's also doing the next fantastic
four movies so he is someone who you
would think
that um that marvel has in mind for
future plans and kang in the comics is
more of a villain to the fantastic four
than the avengers
um but kang is at least confirmed to
appear in quantum mania
most likely in loki's season two and
still a very good chance to be the
villain of john watt's fantastic four
film maybe they just didn't hire him yet
for that movie
title and also there's probably a good
chance we're gonna see
a young avengers title in the works we
have pretty much all the young avengers
characters
cast in the mcu uh and perhaps a fifth
avengers film like secret invasion but
the question mt i think is how long the
mcu will exist
as this chaotic multiverse like we know
some titles will embrace the multiverse
doctor strange the multiverse madness no
way home
but others good chance will be
unaffected by the multiverse
events titles like shanghi secret
invasion thor love and thunder guardians
vol 3 which james gunn has said has been
written in its present form for years
before
you know marvel unleashed this
multiverse um now we
have heard some unconfirmed talk from
some
sources based off of people who work
here at new rock stars who have
something but none of it's confirmed so
it's carmen san diego don't lie to them
it's carbon san diego right
we got some deep throats i don't trust
any of these sources
currently to really hang any hats on
this but
just some gossip that the tva might
appear in a marvel title
before loki season two
grain of salt big grain of salt okay
but really when it comes to kang and the
multiverse marvel i believe has two
paths before it uh there is a four-year
multiverse plan
and a ten-year multiverse plan i feel
like i'm getting a mortgage or something
yeah oh yeah yeah right but both are
great deals you got to act now
the four-year plan would treat the
multiverse as a transitional crisis
touched on in titles like no way home
multiverse madness quantomania fantastic
four maybe deadpool 3
avengers secret wars and they kind of
wrap up by like 2025
and this would end with the multiverse i
would think condensing back into one
shared universe
really this would just be like a phase
four they've been
they haven't really used the term phase
four a lot we don't know if it's gonna
be like another
phase that tends to last four or five
years or just like
now for the foreseeable future we this
is just what we're in now
but then after that i think is when we
would move on to the x-men
who might get introduced in universe as
opposed to from
another universe um and then i think in
that case
kang would be thwarted or downgraded to
like a red skull or loki
level villain in the universe but really
leave the door open for
like doctor doom or galactus or magneto
or mephisto
or someone like that to be the main
primary villain
so that would be the four-year plan
contrastingly the 10-year plan
would treat the multiverse as really
just the new normal like
all upcoming mcu stories would exist
either because of
or in spite of the existence of a
fractured multiverse
but either way in a multiversal context
that could be used to explain the movie
or tv show's interconnectivity
or explain its elseworld independence
this version of it would probably use
the multiverse to justify the x-men and
would give us a better chance of seeing
characters like evan peters or michael
fassfender people from
that universe bridging over with ours uh
and then compared to the infinity saga
this would just be our multiverse saga
the infinity saga lasted
roughly 10 years so with this uh
and in this version of it kang might not
be the only villain
but he would be the most fearsome threat
for
all of this period because he can just
show up in so many different forms
yeah it just depends on i don't know if
marvel's made up its mind yet
i think they're probably weighing both
of these versions i think they're
probably playing a wait-and-see
game currently because as james gunn
said this week we'll talk about this uh
later in the episode
the superhero genre might not be
something that lasts forever
um and you got to imagine marvel studios
is probably going to want to go for
broke
and adapt a lot of these popular things
while they are still popular
uh in pop culture we don't know if uh
you know superhero movies are just gonna
be like
action movies and action movies are
always popular you know since
the 80s really the 70s but the 80s kind
of distilled what action movie
formulas were uh or audiences will just
look at it as like
sci-fi or just escapist fantasy or if
it's gonna be something like the western
and the western really did peak at some
point and kind of went out of style
and not to say that the western movie
genre is gone and done with obviously we
have movies like the coen brothers make
perfectly great westerns uh uh
unforgiven in the 90s was kind of a
deconstruction western
we got that black cowboy movie coming
out on netflix and i'm totally forgotten
forgetting the name of but it looks
amazing
but western movies all kind of have to
be uh they're all deconstructions
rather than just like you know back in
the 60s 50s and 60s
like you can westerns were all over the
place and you could just pump out a
formulaic western and audiences would
see it
that's not really the case anymore um
but nt i want to ask you
which of these two paths the four-year
plan or the ten-year plan do you think
marvel studios might be leaning towards
and which plan do you
want to be the case i think that it
might be more of a 10-year plan type of
scenario
um because like you know i feel like you
know this
is marvel's way of like you said
integrating the x-men and sort of
making these the sony and fox universes
and the marvel studio universes
into one shared universe and having the
general public
understand the difference in like how
everything's been since
you know 2000 whenever the first x-men
movie came out
uh because to this point it's been very
confusing for a lot for the general
audience it's like
wait why isn't uh professor x with uh
you know the avengers like what's going
on like why isn't wolverine here
and so this uh with loki season one
we're getting the introduction of the
multiverse and we're getting
the public understanding there and i
think this is just very much the
beginning
of you know greater tales being told
with the multiverse being the offshoot
so like with kang
kang is very much the like the beginning
phases of a bigger
multiversal story so we're gonna get
kang
but then i think that we're gonna
transition into a secret wars into
maybe like you know the power of the
beyonders that you know doom wields
when he becomes god doom in the um in
the secret wars
story from 2015. so you know we i think
that
kang is just you know he might be he's
definitely going to be the ant-man
villain we're definitely going to see
that play out
um but after kang is defeated i think
that we're
gonna just move forward towards some
more multiversal threats because like
the ancient one said in doctor strange
one if you knew that all the threats
in the multiverse should run away in
terror and then at the end of doctor
strange one
um wong says that uh because the ancient
one is dead
everyone in the multiverse is gonna get
here get word of this
and then want to converge onto our
reality so we have multiversal threats
pretty much on the um been coming to us
we've like since doctor strange won uh
since the death of the ancient ones so
like
marvel studios has definitely been
planting the seeds towards
the more bigger cosmic threats
on the horizon so like we're talking
like you know maybe the
builder war or maybe a um a war with the
annihilation wave because we we have a
fantastic four coming up
um but yeah i think it's more of a
ten-year pled sorry just rambling at
this point
i ramble all the time baby we were born
rambling men
[ __ ] man we do but i think um i think
you're right i don't know if
general audiences feel like a confusion
of why isn't wolverine in this i think
that's something that it's limited to
people like us
in the bubble um but i think like most
people who watch marvel movies they
just are you know they take what they
get and
they'll just kind of like take it one
step at a time rather than feeling like
they are being deprived of anything um
but i do think that um right now
marvel's kind of in a wait and see
approach they probably don't want to to
use a crash turn blow their wad
on multiverse too soon i think they
want to like you know just take it
cautiously
a little bit at a time but i think what
we saw with jonathan majors he's such a
great actor
he could be what loki has been just kind
of one of these villains who shows up in
little bits and pieces here and uh you
know i think what kevin feige's ultimate
dream has been to make the marvel
cinematic
universe everything that marvel
readers have loved about the comics
which is just a sense of like we don't
always need to have a bird's-eye view of
the exact stakes uh from
world to world but once you are in
one particular story you're able to kind
of put up blinders to
the stakes in the context of everything
else of the world
and just stay focused on this one
character's journey
moment to moment um so that might mean
the mcu over the next
four to ten years might not have an
exact sense of continuity
that it once had in the infinity saga
but potentially i think why not go for
broke and just see how far you can
stretch it
and how things relate like i think we
will probably see something like the cat
in britain core
right or like the spider verse right
it's gonna get
complicated and crazy and messy but like
i never would have thought that they
could have adapted an infinity war
saga and brought in all these characters
and have them talk to each other and
they all still kind of retain their
individual identity
so i think marvel's doubling down it
looks like
uh and while i do think there will be
other villains beyond kang
i don't think we're gonna see a
four-year plan where kang is done
and then one new big bad is introduced
because because
marvel's already done that with thanos i
think instead what you're gonna see is
like more of a 10-year plan
and then kang is one villain but then
like
in certain movies yeah as you said
there's an annihilation situation
there's dr doom and so i don't think
that when we get a secret wars movie
it's going to be kang
i think it's going to be doom you know i
don't think they're just going to use
kang for everything oh no they're going
to
be lazy yeah yeah why not like cast
other people
like who knows how long superhero movies
are going to be popular so
now that you own dr doom again don't
wait
i don't think feige wants to wait yeah i
don't think so either i think doom is
very much on the horizon
and he's going to be a huge driving
force because
you know like you said with kevin feige
kevin feige has been wanting
these fox properties so much and like
you could tell that he's been wanting to
have the fantastic for it and to treat
them right so like doom is definitely
going to be
a major force within the mcu when he is
introduced but like also another
thing that we have to consider here is
that like disney plus and what marvel
studios is doing with disney plus
is still rather new and what we
understand the mcu now
is going to be a lot different than what
we've experienced in the last 10 years
these last 10 years we've had only
movies but now the mcu is is sort of
progressing at a much faster clip
because we have movies and we also have
these shows and so we're getting so
we're getting so much
we we're so blessed which is amazing but
like i think that that
might sort of that may end up condensing
phases
or condensing um how long phases go or
how long sagas even go
in terms of time because we're now
getting more stories being told
in uh you know per year which is great
yeah i think that's right i think uh
phases were
something that feige did to make it
clear to
shareholders and investors right how
what his plan was
but now that he can say look we have a
streaming app we can release content
whenever we want multiple times a year
like realistically we're looking at a
point to where every week
with minor interruptions we'll have a
new piece of mcu lore
coming into our lives that i think is
even more preferable to
investors and shareholders because then
it's like forever in perpetuity
we will have new content coming out why
do we need to break this up into phases
anymore
right um this could just be as popular
for as long as we can convince people to
subscribe to disney plus to get this
stuff
you get eight dollars a month out of
them and potentially a lot more
oh yeah it's definitely hiking up 18
bucks 30 bucks sorry folks we're gonna
have to start paying a lot more for this
oh yeah if they're gonna keep shelling
out all this money for all these high
quality shows like we're
we're gonna have to cough it up yeah
anyway let's move on to some people
helped us make this episode we want to
thank beals for sponsoring this episode
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you don't feel stress anxiety pain
other things that make you feel bad well
feels is a better way to feel
better feels is a premium cbd that will
help to keep your head clear
and feel your best it's hassle free and
delivered directly to your door become a
member and get 50
off your first order cbd naturally helps
reduce stress anxiety pain and
sleeplessness there's no hangover or
addiction
i've used cbd in the past to help with
aches and pains and a bunch of us here
new rockstars are big fans of cbd
placed a few drops of feels under your
tongue and feel the difference within
minutes feels offers a free cbd hotline
and a dedicated customer service team
to help guide your personal experience
so that you find a perfect dose joining
the fields monthly membership makes your
self-care
easy you'll save money on every order
and you can pause or cancel any time
start feeling better with feels become a
member today by
going to feels.com marvel and you'll get
50 off your first order with free
shipping that's
f e a l s dot com slash marvel to become
a member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free
marvel we also want to thank bluechu for
sponsoring this video our friends at
bluetooth have a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost fluchu is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive your
prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength
and blue shoe is chewable just like it
says in the name which is great news for
folks that don't like swallowing pills
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when use the
promo code of
inside marvel at checkout just pay the
five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code
insidemarvel to receive your first month
free and we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring the show
and thanks to betterhelp for sponsoring
this show we've all experienced times
when something was interfering with our
happiness and preventing us from
achieving our goals
well betterhelp is here to help they
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
who you can start communicating with
in under 48 hours it is not a crisis
line it's not self-help it is
professional counseling done securely
online they have a broad range of
expertise available for
clients worldwide log into your account
anytime and schedule weekly video or
phone sessions
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today
check out the reviews section of their
website for testimonials from folks who
have gotten something from their service
visit betterhelp.com marvel that's
better h-e-l-p and join the over 1
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
and here's a special offer for the
inside marvel audience get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
marvel all right mt shifting gears here
why do we still not have a spider-man no
way home trailer and when do you think
we will get it
well i think the answer is simple eric i
think sony just wants us to suffer
because i think that's just what's going
on here
no i think honestly there i think
there's some
it's like sort of half true there
because like they don't
have to release the spider-man no hue
hoe trailer so soon because
we all want it so badly like if you go
to twitter.com
it is all anyone is talking about in the
nerd
corner of twitter and like you know
we're sort of doing free marketing for
them in a way
so it's just like hey everyone's
thinking about no way home everyone's
waiting for it so they're sort of just
like hold
hold hold and then they're gonna release
it
um so we're gonna get it very soon
because obviously no way home is coming
out
you know pretty freaking soon um but god
i don't know
exactly what what do you what do you
think why do you think that we haven't
seen one yet because no one said that we
would
i think right like no one from sony
promised us that we would get a trailer
i'm like i feel bad because i uh
obviously i want to see it
um but i think yeah you're right
i think sony recognizes that there's a
whole industry of people like
us and other channels like us and other
scoopers who make these promises
and use that to you know get traffic to
their channels and their websites
uh and then they're making this up based
on nothing they're saying i have a
source that says the trailer will come
out tomorrow
and then inevitably it's wrong i mean
this movie is not coming out
until december we are at the end of july
right now
like i would you know i could totally
see this trailer not dropping until
september or october
like if you think this time last year
for all the big stuff that marvel was
announcing
for the fourth quarter like we didn't
see a mandalorian or a one division
trailer until october
right you know we kept saying oh it's
gonna come next week
these things are gonna happen by the end
of the year it has to come next week and
then not till october
did we get anything um so yeah
unfortunately we may have to wait a bit
longer
um i know i i want to know more about
this movie too
but yeah sony's marketing is weird
so just to like remind you guys the
people who
cut trailers for sony every time whether
it's venom let there be carnage or this
ghostbusters afterlife trailer
their marketing department is just a bit
weird
they often seem to be out of sync with
their own directors
and their own writers and their own team
that makes these movies
and often the tone of their trailers and
the timing of their releases
is just odd uh and
and it's it doesn't have this um
wonderful synergy that the walt disney
corporation seems to have
like cutting these trailers that like
seem to read their fans minds they know
exactly what we want
so like i would even say brace yourself
for this spider-man no way home trailer
to just be a bit disappointing
to not be something that you would
imagine john watts cutting together
because i don't know what it is sony
trailers are often just
weird they drop in the middle of the
freaking night sometimes
uh and it's it's not always like going
to be
synced with a big disney release or an
abc production broadcast on tv
because disney and sony are different
studios and with these like
uh co-produced movies of these
spider-man movies disney doesn't have
any say
really on how it's marketed that's all
sony so
just remind yourselves of the uh
spider-man homecoming trailer of the
spider-man part from home trailers
they were just like a little weird uh
they didn't always like
i don't want to get too much into it i
think i just remember seeing the
spider-man homecoming trailer being like
really they're using that song
like all right i'll go watch this movie
but it looks kind of dumb
and then the movies came out and they
were great because john watts is a great
director
um but yeah i just i don't i don't i'm
not gonna try to
read sony marketing's mind on how
they're gonna release this trailer i've
just
i've been burned too many times i just
really hope that
you know my biggest concern with um with
trailers for the initial
trailer for like big properties like
spider-man
is that you know they they rely so much
on name recognition
and all of that in in in crafting their
trailer so that they don't they just
don't show us anything
it's just like here's the back of
spider-man and now you're excited
and like we didn't show you like like
plot or like what's going on with them
like
what's going on in in the story of this
movie it's just like
oh we're gonna tease you with like your
spider-man swinging and then he was like
i don't know some
electricity going on because like that's
sort of hinting at electrode and then
he's gonna make our jobs to like
decipher all the
little cryptic clues and like they're
not gonna show us anything so that's my
biggest concern
please just show us what this movie's
gonna be about
and also yeah um i'm also looking
forward to um
the amazing posters that we're going to
get from sony because their posters are
always posters
their posters are always so weird and
terrible but it's always now that the
poster they release will not be as good
as the fake fan made posters that we've
seen so far
i i would be like why can't we just use
these instead right i co-signed that
um yeah i like the fake ones all right
some other news we got from the mcu this
week michaela cole
from um uh i may destroy you from black
mirror a bunch of stuff great actress
was cast in black panther wakanda
forever
uh what role do you think she's gonna
play empty see this is really
interesting because i've been sort of
like racking my head around this and i i
don't really know
exactly what role she would play but it
would be really really fun
if she were playing killmonger's mother
because in
the mcu um i think that in canon
she died in prison if i'm not mistaken
um
well you know and then you know his
father was eric's father was doing you
know criminal stuff against wakanda
yeah i think that it'll probably be a
flashback sequence where she's playing
killmonger's mom because we don't see
that character at all
and i feel like her character is really
interesting um so it'd be
really cool to see her pop up and be
like you killed my baby i can't believe
you all killed my baby now you're all
going to die
um i mean the popular theory is storm
right aurora monroe
i just don't know i i think michaela
cole would be a great
storm don't get me wrong i just think
like the only reason you would have
storm in a black panther movie is to see
her relationship with t'challa and if
t'challa's not gonna be in this movie i
don't know if you can really
i mean you could try i just i don't know
what story you would tell
otherwise yeah um but uh
i think like we've her hair has been cut
short in a lot of her past rolls i would
imagine
like a new member of the dora melange um
right just because like if you think
like and um
i may destroy you when her character had
that hair
like yeah i she's great head is what i'm
saying she's got a great head
she could play a great member of the
door millage yeah i think that adora
melanche
scenario is most likely considering that
you know um
that's the nature of like the like what
black women
in what kind of society they're usually
the strong soldier type figures
um so i feel like dora milaje would be
interesting i think it'd be really
interesting if she was like a uh
like a competition for okoye like in a
way like she's trying to gun for okoye's
top spot or something
like that'd be really cool to see like
uh see them go at it i don't know but
she could be literally
anyone i mean depending on we still
don't know what the story is going to be
about
like if it does show if it's about
wakanda forever maybe this is about like
the collapse of wakandan society in a
civil war or something like that and
maybe there's like a divide between
the door that like there's some warring
sides between
the ranks are among the ranks of that
particular group and that
uh michaela cole could play a rival to
deny guerrero's
character and and ao as well um
we'll see uh but she's a great actress
i'm excited to see what role
she is at playing uh but let's move on
to ant-man the was quantum mania
peyton reed tweeted this week that
there's uh their beginning production he
had this
terrifying stuffed rabbit sitting next
to a tank labeled biohazard
so any new thoughts on what quantomania
could be after the loki finale as we're
moving forward
well i i first of all i love that
picture because i love that little bunny
from ant-man one because that's the
bunny that uh ant-man
scott lang gives his daughter in the
first movie for right right party
um but but in regards to any new
thoughts on fundamental after the loki
finale i mean
you know like i've been saying before i
definitely think we're gonna see kang
in um quantum mania in a kid king
obviously because like obviously king's
gonna be in quantum mania because he's
going to be
the main villain but i think we're going
to see a younger version of kang
in quantum mania as um basically that
iron lad
version of of king and those seeds are
going to be planted in quantum anion
because
in the comics uh kang young kang and
stature uh who is
cassie lang in in the ant-man series
um have sort of like a relationship
thing going but they're also
young avengers together and so i think
that cassie will probably meet
a variant of king but that's pretty much
my only and then we're probably going to
see lots of variants of kane because
because of the name quantum mania
they're probably going to be jumping to
different universes all over the place
different timelines or whatever
and so we're we're probably going to see
different a ton of different kangs um
as kang is this main villain so it will
probably be like this mini
army of kangs that it's got is trying to
fight yeah i agree
i think uh quantum mania is just going
to be centered or at least take place
partly in that city in the background of
the quantum realm
um whether it's chronopolis or whatever
it is and i think the kang variant we'll
see and this one will be kang the
conqueror
yeah for sure like i i don't think
there's going to be any confusion about
it like that's the villain
yeah and i think you're right i think
there's going to be alternate versions
of him that may be worrying with himself
but yeah i think the
the spin-off from this movie will be
young avengers
you know and i think uh cassie lang
stature is going to be
the lead of that and i think we're going
to meet young nathaniel richards
as you said um they might even use that
version of like uh
how they had that mistake version of
quantum technology that de-aged people
or age people up
like maybe that's the way we get kang is
that some kang variant gets de-aged
uh and then so we get a young nathaniel
richards
out of that that'd be fun i would love
that i just hope that they don't let go
of that particular like i hope that
wasn't just like a one-off scene i'd
love to see that
i know like that like implemented more
in the mcu it's like you just saw the
the cure to aging like by accident
a lot of stuff you can make someone
immortal that way exactly like
forever quick question though what do
you think of the odds of
us going to spiderman 2099's universe in
guantamania
i think it's more likely we'd see that
no way home than in quasimania
right but i do think a miguel o'hara uh
showing up in the
mcu as is possible it would just have to
be through one of these sony properties
i would imagine
because like we do know that sony and
marvel have this new deal going on and
like we don't exactly know
what the deal entails it'll be really
interesting if more spider-man stuff
got implemented in in uh like solo
marvel projects more
i mean i love it i love it it's just
sony's still pretty protective of it
like
it seems like anytime they share the
spider-man name it's just peter parker
for now
it's true like like i don't know if
they're gonna let miles morales show up
uh like other than mention until like we
don't have peter parker anymore
uh but that's gonna be a whole new deal
that i think disney has to sign
with sony i think this releasing uh
their
titles on disney plus is one thing but
actually being written in their movies
is a whole other thing
that we're it's still going to be baby
steps i want to ask you about this quote
from james gunn in an interview for the
suicide squad this week
he uh was asked kind of about the
superhero film genre and he said quote
we know about the way cowboy films went
and the way
war films went i don't know i think you
don't have to be a genius to put two and
two together and see that there's a
cycle to those sorts of films
and that the only hope for the future of
the comic book and superhero films is to
change them up
they're really dumb and they're mostly
boring for me right now
end quote now there's probably a context
to which jameson was saying that this is
the same guy who's making the suicide
squad in guardians of galaxy vol 3.
obviously he's not saying all superhero
movies are dumb and boring i think he's
just saying to change things up to keep
it
fresh and original as he's done in all
of his superhero movies
but what are your thoughts on this empty
i think james gunn's right out like
right on the money there i think that
he's exactly right and
i think we're starting to see it as
superhero films
have gotten more popular in um in just
in the public eye
with other studios who are not marvel
studios like making
trying to hop into that like that
superhero hype
and not actually getting into it because
they don't understand
that you know superhero films have been
around for so long
and that marvel studios is starting to
evolve the way that they
show these films whereas these studios
are like hey we just we just slapped
tights on them right and like it's fine
people will just come see it no it's
like we need to continue
evolving and making um these stories and
these characters new
for example thor ragnarok like thor the
thor series was kind of struggling up
until that point and they reinvented it
and made this
a crazy take on the ragnarok story
that's what you need to do to keep
things fresh and new and that's what
will keep people
interested in the mcu that's why we got
loki that's why ant-man the wah
spontaneous probably gonna be crazy
that's why marvel is even doing this
multiverse stuff to begin with
because they're flipping things up like
the marvel universe
everyone's like yeah we know what the
marvel universe is we we have a pretty
good idea
nope we about to we're about to give you
uh alligator loki and all sorts of weird
[ __ ] because like we flipping up the
game and keeping things interesting
and like that is i think that is what's
going to be the difference between
you know the the western genre and um
you know superhero genre yeah i think
he's um
right that you do have to change things
up i disagree with him on
uh them being comparable to uh western
films and
war films though i don't know if uh it's
a passing fad
i think the fact that you know the first
superman movie we had the batman
series we had other batman movies in the
past but really the superhero movies as
like major motion pictures
it's richard donner superman we had some
superman movies from the 80s we had the
tim burton batman films through the
uh 80s and 90s uh and then we had kind
of this marvel renaissance that really
started with blade
you know but then blade led to x-men
and sony spider-man uh throughout the
2000s and then the mcu launched
i think the difference is is the level
of saturation to have multiple of these
movies per
year but it they keep just making more
and more money i don't know if that's a
bubble
i think they're already transforming and
trying new things even
before james gunn directed guardians of
the galaxy but like
you know if you look at the western film
genre like it did
legitimately go out of style and i don't
know if superhero movies are a genre
uh in the same way because within the
superhero movies you get
heist movies you get period pieces you
get spy thrillers um you get like
comedies straight up like weird douglas
adams comedies
as what like thor ragnarok and guardians
of the galaxy have been
and what i would say loki is um you have
like kind of romantic dramas
that uh feel like something that spike
jones would do
is what uh one division was um
so i don't know if you can really
compare them
uh but the western film genre did go out
of style for sure
um but you it's still around it just
takes new forms
and uh clint one of my favorite movies
is clint eastwood's unforgiven
um and that is a deconstruction of the
western film genre
and of stories in general uh and
mythology
and um the superhero movies already kind
of went through that james mangold's
logan
was almost beat for beat unforgiven it's
i
highly recommend if you have like a
double feature night watch unforgiven
and then watch logan
or watch one of the two back to back
it's you'll see the parallels and you'll
love both movies
even more than you thought so yeah i
think uh
and then things like the dark knight
that was a deconstruction of the batman
mythology
uh six years before guardians of the
galaxy was
so yeah i don't think they have to go
out of style but i do think
they i don't think there's like a
pressure cooker limit i think people
will still
you can still make a straight up
formulaic marvel movie and i think
people will watch it ten years from now
uh the ip is that strong it's
unprecedented but i don't think
everything is a bubble
this is true and i think that with with
the fact that we have a cinematic
universe and we have this narrative
that is being told over such a long
period of time with
no end in sight i think that that
intrigue there is what's going to keep
superhero films alive
we'll leave it there for this episode of
inside marvel but mt and i are going to
be back next wednesday with
our preview from marvel's what if on
disney plus why this anthology series
will actually be essential viewing to
prepare for titles like multiverse of
madness so stay tuned for that
don't forget to check out our mini great
merch options at nyrocstarsmirch.com
follow mt at mastertainment follow me at
eavos follow me rockstar subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast
thank you for joining us and we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
you